I'm selling the Xbox on Craigslist and somebody's like, "cool sounds good, can I get it from you?" I'm like "sure"
"Well I will offer you $380 and I'll PayPal you to ship it to me" and I'm like wait,
"Why are you paying me a hundred more dollars than you can do to buy it brand-new on Amazon?"
"Well, actually I'm uh... I'm
currently in Brooklyn purchasing for a colleague outside the state, uh..
I'll provide you the shipping address and transfer the money as soon as I get the request"
"But... you could buy the exact same thing on Amazon for $100 less," it's like well,
"But yours is new and I prefer to buy it from you because, they will charge me more for the shipping and necessary tax."
*Stifled Laugh*
Amazon was like, "$308 with shipping and tax that's still... still $70 less." Why would you... <pull them along?>
I'm just constantly asking like, innocent questions about this whole thing.
I'm just really curious about how I can get himself out this whole, "offer me way too much money."
<But how is he scamming you if he's offering you more money?>
Because he's just going to, the moment I ship it
he's just gonna charge back the PayPal. <I got you>
Find out whether or not I get scammed, subscribe to *laughs* the sam and niko channel, uh spoiler alert
I won't be. But, other spoiler alert, fun things can still happen because... talking to scammers, is fun!
Yo
I gotta take this. "Hello? okay cool"
Yeah, you know what makes me feel good? <What?> you know what makes me feel good?
Dude, check out all that you see, all these URLs right here
You see all those? You know what those are? Facebook. copyright notices.
<*Laughing*>
Yeah, PUGB video came out and,
Over 27 Facebook pages promptly re-uploaded it
I'm just gonna walk you through the argument. Right now, 'cause, the people that are *SUBSCRIBE* at me for doing this, here,
Here's what you're thinkin'. "I gave you guys credit."
"I put Corridor in the link."
"Yeah, and you still ripped our video from YouTube, and re-uploaded it onto your own channel, onto Facebook,"
"Which is probably *SUBSCRIBE*-ing monetized 'cause half Facebook pages are nowadays."
Don't expect me not to get *SUBSCRIBE*-ed about that. We put a lot of work into that video.
And we have a Facebook page. (Yeah)
And we, and I just uploaded it to Facebook or actually, okay. It's don- wait here- hold on holdonholdon
And I just published it to Facebook.
It's just you know it-it-it
started it here, in the States, last year and,
Everybody *SUBSCRIBE*-ing re uploading stuff from YouTube onto Facebook and,
all the YouTube creators were like, "take-down take-down take-down"
And they started yelling at Facebook and Facebook was like, "oh well, uh," [and] Facebook implemented a policy where anytime you get a copyright notice
of takedown on your Facebook page, you can't upload a video for three days. And a lot of these channels upload
10-15 videos a day- that's all they do- they just scan the internet, they steal, re-upload
And they scan the internet, they steal and re-upload. No. Not okay.  Guys, I'm not gonna swear
'cause, you know what? You're not even worth a swear out of me. the point is <don't do it>
Who couldn't post for three days anymore?
Now- and no- and now they can't post for three days, and now I see it spreading into other parts of the world.
It's dissipated here, you don't see it as much here.
And now, oh, guess what? People email us and very kindly ask us if they can re-upload our Facebook videos now,
Then we kindly say "no."
For the record, if you'd like to- you know what before we even go down this road
I'm going to show you the epitome of why this fires me up.
<Your biscuits are-> My biscuits are getting *SUBSCRIBE*-ing TOASTED, dude.
Okay, <Checking?> Okay. Are you checking? And this is what it is. Actually,
I haven't taken the time to take this down yet, okay? <Richard Ford?> this- this- video
*moment of realization summarized in an amazing sucking of air*
<THIS GUY!> This *censor*-ing guy,
Richard Ford, <He got a swear outta you!> if you're watching-
Oh, he did, *SUBSCRIBE*. He *SUBSCRIBE*-ing did.
<He's got three outta you!>
*DAB*
THIS guy,
This guy's a real gem. He's a real gem, because, this is exactly what happens, okay, yeah
Richard Ford over here with his 221 subscribers, and he's just got a YouTube account, he's not bothering anybody
He's just a freaking guy probably a nice guy. If I met him I'd probably have a beer with him
Who knows? Maybe he's a dick. Just like everyone else, he saw, Bohemian Rhapsody, either on our
Facebook where we uploaded it. Or on our YouTube page where
WE uploaded it. And then, just like a bunch of other people, ripped it from YouTube
And they re-uploaded it to Facebook. They were so rampant,
It BECAME so rampant that not everyone knew where the original source of the content was.
THAT is the inherent problem; Is that IF
people take our videos off of YouTube,
And they re-upload them to Facebook, then,
more and more people do that. And then at a certain point no one knows who the original poster was.
That's the point, and then you end up with a situation like, /this/
*Giggle* <What- What is this?>
I see this on Casey Niestat's comment section a lot.
But apparently, someone took our name, and our avatar, and is commenting as us,
In bold as spam
And they're linking to a Playstation 4 giveaway. <It's Sam and Niko_ > Underscore.
Hey, Christian, are we able to delete their channel?
<Or is there like no?..> I mean they're commenting on everyone's stuff
<I mean you've probably seen this before.> I have seen this before.
It's very difficult because you can start hiding, or marking it as spam, blah-blah-blah
So easy for them to make another display name, another YouTube name if they really want to keep it going.
They more they steal our channel art the easy it is for the takedown
but it's just so easy to just take a display name and
vary it a little bit. This comes with the more and more popularity you get on a channel.
<So- So in a way it's a badge of success?> A little bit, for sure.
'Cause, yeah I've dealt with tons of spam accounts going on,
making it look exactly like the poster being like, "click here for an iPhone giveaway" it makes everybody go to this... spam site.
I've sat there for hours before literally clicking hide for- hide for comment stream.
So, I'm gonna hide comments and report spam. <Oh yeah>
Hide this user
So you can keep doing that and (and then) and that will, that will trigger (Report spam) and that will trigger the algorithm somewhere
Trigger somebody that like "somethings going on" but like
The more you do it and the more people see it also sometimes the more fired up they get and they do it more
<That's not us, if we ever do a PlayStation 4 giveaway. We will make a segment about it.> Yep
Richard Ford *clears throat* I keep getting odd comments and people deleting them
So let me make this clear corridor shared this along with
CollegeHumor 9gag and pretty much anyone else who thought it would go viral and promote their page so Corridor's
just like everybody else just reposts in somebody else's cool video and
And if there was any copyright infringement
Which there isn't. That's just that's just a flat-out lie. This would monetize directly to the person claiming rights in which it would be
Divided by around 40 people because that's how many people re uploaded it
Duh it gets better
So please keep your shitty comments off of here
Corridor is well aware of my posting and I of them posting it along with the thousands of others who have ripped it and shared
It on Facebook instead of getting credit to everyone in it, and the ones who made it
Wait who made the video hello actually clearly
Clearly it wasn't corridor CollegeHumor 9gag or the thousands of other people who ripped it, and we uploaded it
Given to us by the internet gods
It was like it was like there's like a viral fruit tree Johnny Boz made that video so that that is the that is the?
Epitome of what I'm trying to avoid here, it's one thing to upload it and give us credit, but now that Facebook's monetize
That's not really a thing either. We upload our videos natively to Facebook. Just freak and share the video from the corridor digital page or
I'm gonna send you a copyright notice and you're not gonna be able to upload videos for three days
So that's my remedy if you want to be a dick beyond that like go ahead
We're trying to make a living doing this and it's really frustrating when people like just straight up
Just straight up take your video and reupload it
like you're
Honestly cut out your income and cut your title card so that it doesn't say court or digitally yeah the beginning of the
Court reads it every video at the beginning to say corridor
Yeah
You know what we should do it was about to do it before you walked over here with that camera scribe you on camera fine
YouTube copyright reform
Inappropriate content trademark infringement copyright infringement who's affected I am exclamation my company is more accurate
removed URL
Litoral Litoral Litoral both
In Episode II where does this continent pier entire video dude? I got kids man
You know and Sam's gonna be Sam's gonna say. He's got kids too soon
You know what the funny thing is that when we started making YouTube videos that were based on
Mario and Master Chief and things like that. I have a funny feeling that the major
Movie studios in town who helped popularize some of those characters and now own them probably felt the same way
But this is this is another level. This is just just straight-up. Just taking something and taking Joss
am saying
And being like you know what everyone should shut describe about Stephen steel
we're trying to take this video down because like he just like any everybody else and
Yes, yeah
Has seen it and then put it in a bunch of theaters and like you know
Keeping a bunch of money out of it
we should just guys we should all really just be thankful for the
Classic blockbuster gods for having delivered that to us one day. I don't know why everyone is such a dick about it
Yeah in slow motion they just bounce down a golden stairway from movie heaven I got to come into Facebook though
They're there copyright takedown
It is
Really efficient Robert Ford
You're welcome
I would do this, but I don't
Talking points, so I'm just gonna spit well, and then we can work out the talking points later
Here's the thing this video is sponsored by Squarespace
That's great, and all I mean the real reason why I wanted to do an integration with them
And I wanted to tell you about Squarespace is because I actually use their platform
I use it for Sam Gorski comm which isn't done yet?
I use it for corridor digital comm used to have a website of my own that I use it for personal
Testimonial here in no way I don't even know what the talking points are yet?
I haven't read them, so this is just speaking from the heart four years ago
I set out to build the first corridor - digital comm website. I used one of their competitors
It was janky. It was super slow. It was a bad website, then I used another one of their competitors
There's a little bit better
It still was like really pretty limited in terms of what you could do with it and the templates were pretty pretty gosh-darn
Janky, and then Nico's now-wife girlfriend at the time IV was like hey you should consider using Squarespace
I make squarespace's with my Squarespace account and you could - and I thought hmm IV knows a lot about design
I'm gonna take her advice and I checked it out, and you know what I'm glad
I did cuz look at our website now
It's half decent saying a lot coming from a guy that doesn't know anything about Web Design
Things you should know about Squarespace. I mean number one. They have beautiful award-winning templates
You know work on mobile tablets desktops who even knows what the Internet's gonna be on next Squarespace has an all-in-one platform
Meaning that you don't need to leave the platform
or add a bunch of code or or patch the
Or upgrade you just work off your template and what you need Squarespace does the rest to make your Squarespace?
Well really cool a feature that I just discovered recently
Is you can also have them post your URL say you are new to the URL game
And you're like you know what I don't want to have to go through a third party host in order to get my URL
I just want to make one account and make a website for it well
You can do that with lastly Squarespace is great for any kind of website
They've got musicians that use their site artists restaurant even like law firms and accounting firms
Whether you need a domain website or online store make your next move with Squarespace start your free trial today at squarespace.com
And use the offer code Sam and Nico to get 10% off your first purchase of it
That's it you guys already know
I should see I should all see websites from all of you and actually if you have a really cool website
And you want to show how much of a better web designer you are than me all you need to do is go to corridor
digital comm see the pretty decent website that I built with no experience using Squarespace and then
Compare it to your own posted on the corridor subreddit. We'll check it out, and if you are a really talented web designer
We'd be interested in hearing from you
So I've been texting back and forth with a scammer trying to get him to
justify why he was going to pay me three hundred eighty dollars for a brand new Xbox that cost two hundred eighty dollars because he
Like you know they try to get you with your greed. You know they like three hundred eighty dollars
I'm gonna be rich shove off your xbox of Nigeria
You know get paid, but it was way too obvious they blew it there should have offered me like three hundred dollars
And then I would be like okay. Well I still win the soul send it because you know we're I'm chip stuff on Craigslist
I'm a PC gamer, bro. I mean why not give it away because I want to use that money to buy a graphics card
I'm sorry, but when you give stuff away one winner and everybody else is a loser
I don't know. I'm a big fan of everybody to be winners, so what happened just seem practical here
Yes, I quit this backing run so anyways this guy's trying to hook me in it's like I wanna pay shipping in taxes
I'm like even with shipping and taxes on amaz. It's 300 bucks. Why are you paying the $80 more?
It's trying to get him to work himself in the hole and little by little I could because grammar is getting worse and worse with
Each leg said you know texted. He's setting me. It's probably different person each time. Anyways eventually Mike okay
Where do you want me to ship it to and sure enough?
He falls right into the cliche and asked me to send it to Nigeria like come on. It's like really
Yeah, you got to change it up a little bit guys like it's been a joke on internet since like 15 years ago
He was not a prince. I think princess need Xboxes
I mean, I don't need to go to ebay for them either way
I followed up with one last question be like look
I've been obviously trying to scam you from the very first time you started talking to me
But before you go, cuz I know you'll never talk to me again at this text
Please dad just answer one question for me like how often does this actually work?
They haven't heard back yet